president Trump appeared on CNN last
night the town hall was a big win for
Trump I don't just say it because I like
the guy even liberal journalists and
politicians are admitting it it was a
big win for republicans in that the
appearance taught us by my count five
important facts about where the Trump
campaign stands right now and the
appearance was even a big win for the
libs as they now have an excuse to
prosecute Trump for committing murder on
National Television I'm Michael Knowles
this the Michael Knowles show
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to this show in just a
moment we will answer a question that
liberals raise
very often at least a few times a year
this one came from Joy Behar on The View
the question is why don't the police
just shoot people in the leg a question
that keeps the libs up at night we'll
get to that in a second first though
we've got to get through this town hall
if you didn't watch it I recommend you
watch the whole thing it was absolutely
delightful it was delightful largely
because Trump totally owned the libs
with facts and logic and it was it was
just
marvelous to watch you kind of felt like
you had that old energy back again right
but the reason that I want to cover it
and I'll I'll try to do it relatively
quickly I want to hit on Five Points
because I think that the Trump Town Hall
appearance Beyond delighting everybody
with Trump's zingers showed us five
important things about his 2024 campaign
first one is Trump is going to bring
receipts they were breaking into the
capital smashing windows and drink
police officers why did you why did it
take you three hours to tell them to go
home I don't believe it did oh let me
pull it out
yeah
so so
if you look at
on January 5th the day before I said
please support our Capitol Police at law
enforcement they are truly on the side
of our country stay peaceful stay
peaceful this was the day before and
this was in the form of Twitter now use
truth truth social I think it's far
superior okay I hope everybody's here I
hope everybody's on truth if you look
January 6 at 2 before 2 30. I am asking
for everyone at the U.S Capitol to
remain peaceful this is right after as
it was happening but what happened is
they took it down I don't know why I
think they took it down because it was
so good they didn't like it being up
there I am asking this is and we didn't
know until I got it back because now I
have 90 million people waiting for me to
go back but I'm on truth and I'm staying
on truth you didn't say anything for 700
hours after actually I did boom and he
just pulls out that sheet of paper this
was in a way an answer to that Infamous
incident between Mitt Romney and Barack
Obama and Candy Crowley the moderator I
think also from CNN back in 2012 when
Mitt Romney said you didn't call the
Benghazi terror attack a terror attack
until long after the attack and Candy
Crowley intervened on Barack Obama's
behave and said actually he did Governor
he did and then it turned out she was
just making that up that wasn't true
this was kind of the opposite where you
had the moderator or the hostess Caitlin
Collins
she says you didn't talk about this for
hours and hours and Trump says I got my
own receipts here we go uh good to know
that it's good to know that Trump is
going to have the facts at his
fingertips when you hear all of these
kinds of charges that are inevitably
going to come up throughout the 2024
campaign next thing it showed us is that
Trump is
thoughtful Trump is thinking in a
nuanced way about major political issues
notably foreign policy
do you want Ukraine to win this War uh I
don't think in terms of winning and
losing I think in terms of getting it
settled so we stop killing all these
people and breaking them
[Applause]
can I just follow up on that you said
you don't think you have to do is
follow up on that because that's a
really important excuse me
can you say if you want Ukraine or
Russia to win this War I want everybody
to stop dying they're dying Russians and
ukrainians I wanted to stop dying
and I'll have that done I'll have that
done in 24 hours I'll have it done you
need the power of the presidency to do
it but you won't say that you want
Ukraine to win you you know what I'll
say I'll say this I want Europe to put
up more money because they're in for 20
billion we're in for 170 and they should
be there and they should equalize they
have plenty of money they should
equalize this is a very thoughtful
answer on Ukraine the liberal view on
Ukraine is rah-rah World War III let's
start dropping bombs on Moscow let's go
after the Kremlin let's assassinate
Putin forget about just chasing Russian
influence out of Ukraine we want Ukraine
to go in and let's have them invade
Russia let's let's go baby NATO on the
Move that's the liberal View
the conservative view is a little more
restrained than that it's a little bit
more conservative the conservative view
is the view that has been articulated by
Statesmen going back 30 years now by
George Kennan author of The Long
Telegram by people like Henry Kissinger
by people like Daniel Patrick Moynihan
and Sam Nunn people who said you know
we've got to be a little bit careful
about how NATO expands and actually
buffer States aren't the worst thing in
the world because they they mediate
between great powers and so what are we
going to do here in Ukraine are we
really going to Route Russia we're going
to call for regime change in Russia what
are we going to do we're going to get
Russia out of Crimea what are we going
to do we're going to invite Ukraine to
join NATO what is that really going to
de-escalate this situation or no is that
going to send us hurtling toward World
War III well you've got China aggressing
in Taiwan and the South China Sea that
doesn't seem to make sense and so so
Trump knows this Trump knows that if he
says I want Ukraine to win first of all
you're going to just be affirming what
Russia's already said which is that the
US is a belligerent in the Ukraine war
and the us is not just waging a kind of
cold war here that the U.S is waging a
hot war with Russia you're only going to
escalate that which is what all the
Liberals and the Hawks are doing on this
particular issue and Trump says no I
just want to wind down the conflict
which a lot of wise Statesmen think the
United States could do if it felt that
it were in its interest to wind down the
conflict so really nuanced answer here
for Trump not just a total Dove not just
a total Hawk he's giving a thoughtful
answer the next thing we learned about
Trump is that the guy is still super
funny
I never met this woman I never saw this
woman this woman said I met her at the
front door of Bergdorf Goodwin which I
rarely go into other than for a couple
of charities
I met her in the front door
she was about 60 years old and this is
like 22 23 years ago I met her in the
front door of Bergdorf Goodman I was
immediately attracted to her and she was
immediately attracted to me and we had
this great chemistry we're walking into
a crowded department so we had this
great chemistry and a few minutes later
we end up in a a room a dressing room a
book of Goodman right near the cash
register and then she found out there
locks in the door she said I found one
that was open she found one she learned
this at trial she found one that was
open what kind of a woman meets somebody
and brings them up and within minutes
you're playing hanky-panky in a dressing
room okay I don't know if she was
married then or not John Johnson I feel
sorry for you John Mr President can I no
but think of it they said he didn't rape
her and they didn't I didn't do anything
else either you know what because I have
no idea who the hell she is
can I ask you given your recounting
and then I tell you this but Mr
President are you ready can I can I
swear on my children which I'd never do
I have no idea who this woman this is a
fake Story made up story so it's really
funny I because we could only put a
short clip in there you might lose a
little bit of the context that when he's
recounting that tale at the beginning
he's saying this is her version of
events I walk into Bergdorf Goodman
which I pretty much never did I'm in a
crowded department store and then the
whole rest of it reads like a romance
novel and that last part I think is
important too because Trump obviously
has engaged in hyperbole exaggeration
let's say a little bending of the truth
every now and again and he was a
billionaire playboy for a long time but
at the end there when he says listen to
me I swear on my children and I never do
that I have no idea who this woman is I
this did not happen
one feels that that is sincere one has
the impression that that is sincere and
he's funny the whole time it's the only
way to deflate this they're accusing him
of the worst things you can be accused
of
they're accusing him of rape okay
they're cute and he's saying either you
say no I didn't do it kind of like when
when someone who wants to set you up
they say hey do you still beat your wife
and any way you answer you you look bad
and so what does he do he just makes fun
of the whole situation of this romance
novel situation that that appeared on an
episode of Law and Order SVU seven years
before the woman published her claims he
mocks it he hits you with sincerity it's
very
persuasive on the campaign Trail and
then the final point
that we learned from the CNN town hall
and this is the most important thing I
think for the Trump campaign to convey
to the GOP base is that Trump this go
round at least
intends to be disciplined
you still have not publicly acknowledged
the 2020 election results why should
Americans put you back in the white
house because we did fantastically we
got 12 million more votes than we had in
as you know in 2016. I actually say we
did far better in that election got the
most uh that anybody's ever gotten as a
city president of the United States uh I
think that when you look at that result
and when you look at what happened
during that election unless you're a
very stupid person you see what happens
a lot of the people a lot of the people
in this audience and maybe a couple that
don't but most people understand what
happened that was a rigged election and
it's a shame that we had to go through
it it's very bad for our country all
over the world they looked at it Mr back
to what you just said there though it
was not a rigged election it was not a
stolen election you and your supporters
lost more than 60 court cases on the
election it's been nearly two and a half
years can you publicly acknowledge that
you did lose the 2020 election let me
just go on if you look at through the
vote they found millions of votes on
camera on government cameras where they
were suffering ballot boxes there's even
more to it we had to we had to cut the
clip to keep it a little a little
tighter for the show
Trump at that first debate with Joe
Biden would never have allowed that
woman to get her nonsense interjection
in there Mr President actually fact
check you lost you lost the election was
not rigged it was totally the most Fair
wonderful beep boop election in beep
beep boop there were no questions about
and had this been
the the first debate of 2020 had this
been a less disciplined campaign Trump
would have come in and gotten into a
shouting match with everyone back and
forth he exhibited incredible restraint
there in fact he exhibited more
restraint than I just exhibited even
listening to what she had to say and
there was no question in my mind that
that was intentional and it's to convey
to the GOP base that this campaign is
going to be disciplined
the most important line of the night
most important line of the night
did not come during the town hall the
most important line of the night and
probably the line that bodes best for
Trump's campaign came before the town
hall when Trump announced it
I'll be doing CNN tonight live from the
great state of New Hampshire because
CNN is rightfully desperate to get those
fantastic Trump ratings back
they were ratings like none other and
they want them back so sitting with
sweet little Elisa last night we were
listening to to the town hall and Elisa
said to me she goes seriously though why
why did CNN agree to do this town hall
and then just before I could answer she
answered it herself she goes is it
literally just because they want those
fantastic Trump ratings and the answer
is yes and this is why Trump is going to
get all that free media he got billions
of dollars worth of free media in 2016.
this is why CNN is going to have him
back on this is why they're all going to
have him back on this is why his poll
numbers are going up because you can't
look away you might say well other
political candidates they've proven
themselves to be more effective at
wielding power or more nuanced about
policy or maybe that's true I'm not even
going to weigh in there I'm just telling
you
this guy is a singular political Talent
he's an American original his worst
aspects are American original his best
aspects are American original okay
there's no copy of him now there are
other candidates in the race and there's
one candidate who is posing something of
a challenge to him and while Trump is
demonstrating his campaign prowess on TV
this other guy is passing some really
important legislation down in the State
of Florida which we'll get to in one
second first though how do you sleep at
night I sleep better knowing that we
maybe have a chance at winning 2024 and
I I sleep better regardless of the
election
because of Helix sleep right now go to
helixsleep.com Knowles with everything
going on in the world right now you
could really use a good night's sleep
that's why you got to check out Helix
mattress he likes his harnessed years of
extensive mattress expertise to bring
their customers a truly elevated sleep
experience
they just launched their new Helix Elite
the Helix Elite collection includes six
different mattress models
each tailored for specific sleep
positions and firmness preferences I've
had my Helix for three years now
probably and I absolutely love it night
after night I sleep like a sweet baby
and I want the same for you elix has a
sleep quiz that matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress because why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else okay you
want to be in my mattress I'm a married
man get out of my Boudoir go to
helixsleep.com Knowles take their
two-minute sleep quiz to find the
perfect mattress for your body and sleep
type their flexible payment plans make
it so that a great night's sleep is
never far away Helix is offering 20 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners hurry on over to
helixsleep.com Knowles with Helix better
sleep starts now
so while Trump is dazzling on CNN what's
going on with his primary opponent Ron
DeSantis he's passing some really
important stuff down in Florida
the very different approach to
campaigning
Trump putting on the old Razzle Dazzle
DeSantis keeping his head mostly down
just trying to rack up those legislative
wins to give him more ammo going into
the campaign once he officially
announces so really great news at the
new College of Florida this is a public
liberal arts school in Florida that Ron
DeSantis has taken in a particular
interest in reforming
and some new reform that has been
brought to that college is that the
school will start to accept the classic
learning test which is an alternative to
the SAT it's a standardized college
entrance exam that is meant for students
with classical and Christian educations
so whereas the SAT and the ACT
increasingly are geared toward people
who have received lib crazy educations
the classical learning test will focus
on
the older more traditional
Superior kind of Education
descent has also recently appointed six
conservative leaders and academics to
the new College of Florida Board of
Trustees
point of this is to purge the leftists
out of that school
into a wield some political power the
scientists on top of that just signed
e-verify into law in Florida
so employers are going to have to make
sure that the people they're hiring are
not illegal aliens Florida becomes the
largest state in the country to do so so
different campaign
lease in these early stages
what DeSantis is betting on is that he
can keep his head down rack up win after
win after win not get too much fanfare
not get too much pushback and then when
he makes his announcement he can say
look at my list of accomplishments maybe
I don't have the Razzle Dazzle maybe I'm
not the Entertainer or the showman that
Donald Trump is but I can get the job
done
and Trump's campaign is going to say I'm
a unique figure the libs uniquely hate
me which tells you that maybe I'm the
man for the job I uniquely am able to
own these guys on TV with facts and
logic and my zingers we didn't include
Half the zingers in this and so you
gotta vote for me because
I break the mold because the the way
that the political structure is set up
it is rigged against Republicans
I uniquely break that mold the scientist
is going to say well I got reelected by
a huge margin in Florida and you Donald
Trump lost the 2020 election this is why
Donald Trump has to continue to focus on
the way in which that election was
rigged and I know a lot of people want
to say that there were no problems with
the 2020 election
I don't know look at Pennsylvania look
at the way they changed the election
laws to contradict even the state
constitution there look at those pipes
bursting in the middle of the night look
at how long it took to count to ballots
I look at the way that they spread
widespread mail and I think it's not a
distraction for the Trump campaign to
keep mentioning not to harp on it but to
keep mentioning the issues with the 2020
election because the biggest attack on
Trump is that he lost to Joe Biden once
how's he going to beat him the second
time
they have to focus on that they're
running very they're running in the same
Lane Trump and DeSantis but they're
running very very different campaigns
one of them just got a big showcase
let's let's see what happens when
DeSantis finally goes out there now
Trump is not the only Republican
politician
that the liberal establishment is trying
to throw Behind Bars
another one would be the colorful
representative from New York George
Santos
it's a Witch Hunt because
it makes no sense that in four months
four months five months I've indicted
you have Joe Biden's entire family
receiving
deposits from nine nine family members
receiving money from foreign from
foreign destinations into their bank
accounts it's been years of exposing a
lot of you here have reported on them
and yet no investigation is launched
into them I'm gonna fight you all right
well and I'm just going I'm getting back
there I'm gonna fight my battle I'm
gonna deliver I'm gonna fight the Witch
and I'm gonna take care of claring my
name and I look forward to doing
so we've got a 13 count indictment
against George Santos the the Republican
representative from New York who lied
about his education and his professional
background possibly his sexual desires
maybe his ethnic or religious background
it's all it's a little bit unclear the
13 count indictment
is the kitchen sink it's everything is
he committed wire fraud they say he took
a 500 unemployment check when he really
was working I mean everything they could
find they threw at this guy and he made
false statements to the House of
Representatives blah blah blah okay I'm
not downplaying this I think fraud is
pretty much the worst crime you can
commit I think it is
pretty much the worst sin you can commit
I think that there's a reason that uh
Dante puts the fraudsters in almost the
very lowest pit of Hell
so I'm not defending any of that
but I am looking at the political system
and I'm wondering hold on
the same day
that we see evidence that pretty much
the entire Biden family was on the take
committing the same kinds of crimes that
they're accusing George Santos of
in some cases worse crimes because the
bidens had more power and more influence
that they could sell to make money from
some of the worst people on earth
you're telling me we're going to go
after this random Congressman who's been
in office for five seconds
for these it's it's like going after a a
drug dealer for you know selling a dime
bag of marijuana but you're going to let
the cartel leaders off the hook are you
kidding me
what is this about
would seem to me that Republicans have a
razor thin majority in the House of
Representatives they won an unlikely
seat in New York they see a particularly
weak member of Congress that they can
pinch off and then that's going to turn
the the Republicans thin majority into
an even thinner majority and it's does
not seem to me to be based on principles
or the
blind execution of Justice this seems to
me not quite a Witch Hunt I'm sure
George Santos did all sorts of terrible
things but it seems to me a selective
prosecution by the liberal establishment
to weaken Republicans and I don't think
Republicans should give this any quarter
at all
I think we should totally ignore this
nonsense we should
as a political matter defend George
Santos at least against the predations
of a corrupt Biden doj
I wouldn't trust George Santos with five
dollars to go get me a cup of coffee
but I'm not going to throw this guy
under the bus I'm not going to say he
should be prosecuted I'm not saying he
should resign from Congress no way
give up the bidens
put the bidens in orange jumpsuits and
then talk to me about George freaking
Santos give me a break
absolutely and say now speaking of
hauling people away and Hauling things
away when you have got your friends
coming over for a barbecue you're
probably gonna have to go haul off that
propane tank haul back on a new propane
tank well how about you make it all easy
with cinch right now go to cinch.com use
promo code Knowles the weather is
warming up over here in Nashville which
means that we are gearing up for
backyard barbecues and campfires the
last thing you need to be doing when
you're getting ready to host a barbecue
is driving around worrying about where
to refill your propane grill tank that
is why you got to check out cinch cinch
is a propane grill tank Home Delivery
Service they deliver propane real tanks
right to your door cinch delivers on
your schedule requires no long-term
commitment or subscription plus delivery
is completely contactless you don't have
to wait around at home track the order
on the Cinch app from anywhere whether
you're grilling steaks or firing up the
patio heaters on a cold night cinch's
propane delivery service ensures that
you have the fuel tool you need to make
the most of every moment go online to
cinch.com or download the Cinch app to
order new customers can get their first
tank exchange for just ten dollars with
promo code Knowles kwles that is
cinch.com or download the Cinch app use
promo code Knowles kwles to get your
first tank exchange for just ten dollars
it's a limited time offer you must live
within the Cinch service area to redeem
it visit cinch
c-ynch.com
offer for details you know if we are
made in the image and likeness of God
it means that there is an ethical and
spiritual infrastructure to reality we
are supposed to behave according to The
God Who Made Us in His image
Exodus features a round table of
wonderful Minds who've gathered to
discuss topics like this
through one of the most important books
in the Bible
there's an irony here that
for all the insistence upon
equality
the very foundation for that equality in
Western culture i the idea that human
beings are made in the Imago day in the
image of God has been lost of course so
it's almost as if
because of the erosion of this
Foundation
the drive for equality is stressed all
the more that's that's exactly what
needs you that's exactly what nature
claimed would happen when he wrote well
when he's particularly in Beyond Good
and Evil he said that was that was
inevitable that would be an inevitable
consequence all episodes of Exodus are
now available exclusively for daily wire
Plus members if you haven't seen it
start at the beginning it is well worth
your time join now at dailywire.com
subscribe to watch Exodus
speaking of scams and scammers
not quite we'll move on from George
Santos and the Biden doj we will focus
on
something that isn't even human
focus on AI
there's a story came out last month but
it's just starting to get some attention
of a new AI scam you could find yourself
picking up the phone
hearing a desperate play from a loved
one in the voice of that loved one
begging for money to be sent to that
person's kidnappers
and it could all be a scam
this mom got the scariest phone call of
her life on the other end she hears her
daughter crying she's like Mom I messed
up as she's crying and sobbing then a
man gets on the line and claims he's
kidnapped her 15 year old daughter Bree
he's like listen here I've got your
daughter you're not gonna call anybody
you're not going to call the cop and I
just um put the phone on mute and
started screaming for help the
kidnappers demand one million dollars
before reducing it to fifty thousand I
at that point started screaming at them
that I want to talk to my daughter again
which they refused but here's the thing
her daughter had not been kidnapped and
that was not her begging mom for help
her voice had been duplicated by a
scammer using artificial intelligence
it's Allison this is going to be hard to
believe but I've been kidnapped they
want one million Ransom otherwise they
say they'll hurt me I don't know what's
going to happen they want me to hang up
now I've got to go I love you
that's pretty creepy it's very creepy it
isn't quite there yet there are these
software programs where you can just put
in 30 seconds one minute of voice audio
and and they will be able to clone your
voice and then spit out whatever you
type in in 60 seconds it costs nothing
it could cost five dollars a month but
it's not quite there yet you'd assume if
you were being kidnapped and held for a
million dollars Ransom you probably
wouldn't say hello there Mom I'm very
nervous about being murdered by my
kidnappers please send a million dollars
I love you but it's pretty close
and there have been similar scams in
recent years this happened to my
grandparents actually my grandparents
got a call from a guy said hey it's your
your grandson and you know I need this
amount of money and they gave some
details about this cousin of mine their
grandson and
luckily they kind of got tipped off that
things were a little strange and my
grandpa handed the phone to my grandma
or vice versa something like that and
they figured out what it was but imagine
if the phone call had been in
the person's voice
you're going to see this proliferate it
won't just be six months two years from
now this is going to happen everywhere
like tomorrow and this ties into a story
from the top cyberspy over in Britain
former top cyberspy who says that AI
fakes and lies are going to destroy
Society
so uh this uh
Professor crn Martin is just the latest
figure or top figure from The Tech world
to say that AI is going to quote
undermine the fabric of our society
because we're not going to be able to
trust anything he says quote AI is now
making it much easier to fake things
much easier to spoof voices much easier
to look like genuine information much
easier to put that out at scale so
having a sense of what is true and
reliable it's going to become much more
difficult and that's something that
risks undermining the fabric of our
society this is a fair thing to be
worried about if you can't tell the
difference between truth and falsehood
then you can't have a functioning
Society
this is just an acceleration of the
problem of transgenderism
this is why people are so focused on
transgenderism it's not just because of
the sexual fetishes of a handful of
people and not even because of the
social contagion and not even because
it's now affecting children but because
transgenderism is a means to
transhumanism
because
with transgenderism the premise is we
can't really know what a man is and what
a woman is and so you might be a fella
who wants to have a normal traditional
life and if somehow the surgeries and
the procedures became Advanced enough
that they actually worked and now if a
man tries to chop himself up to look
like a woman you can tell you can 99.9
of the time it's pretty clear that the
the dude who looks like a lady is really
a dude or vice versa but let's say it
did become more advanced you would not
be able to know and so your inability to
discern the truth would certainly affect
your life it'd be very awkward when the
two of you try to have children you know
at 10 years into your marriage you
decide okay maybe we're gonna have a
child and the guy says oh actually um
funny story I'm actually a dude but I
you know so that that would be part of
it
um and the the transhumanism aspect is
that we're just going to modify
our bodies to such a degree that we're
totally untethered from reality but I
think there's a silver lining to the
storm cloud which is yes deep fakes and
cloned voices and fake images and videos
it's going to make it hard to know
whether that that video of a politician
caught in a scandal whether that's real
whether that means that we should kick
the guy out of Congress or the Senate
or is it just a fake
pretty soon we're not going to be able
to know in some ways political scandals
will probably Abate because even if you
catch the guy dead to rights he's got
three hookers and a big bag of crack
cocaine and he got him on three
different cameras the politician could
probably just say yeah well it's a fake
it's a deep fake and you can't prove
otherwise okay yeah that's a bad thing
but
the Silver Lining to that is
politics I think then is going to become
much more local much more immediate it's
going to return to being more
incarnational physical
we're we're going to
be forced to think Beyond
science okay back to the real human
tangible stuff
so I don't know if that phone call I
just heard is real I don't know if that
video I just saw is real but I'm talking
to a politician right in front of me and
I know that guy is real I'm at the Town
Hall I'm in the Town Square I'm gonna I
don't know if I can believe the nonsense
coming out of Brussels or Washington DC
or wherever but I I can trust the people
in my local community you could see a
return to tradition and in fact you are
seeing that now one of the big reactions
against are increasingly
technocratic
metaverse virtual reality kind of
Society is
to leave it to leave the cities to go
out get a little bit of land maybe get
some chickens I don't know maybe you're
going to leave the school system you're
going to start homeschooling your kids
you're going to take a much more active
role in the life of your own family that
means an investment of time and energy
and just your physical presence
that's the reaction now is that going to
compensate for the vast majority of
people who are just going to plug
themselves into the Matrix and that's
that maybe not
but it will present an alternative now
speaking of local politics
e Gene Carroll is the woman
who accused Trump of raping her 27 or 28
years ago we don't really remember and
actually it wasn't rape oh no actually
it was rape and I know the jury didn't
find him liable for rape but so they
think that I'm lying about that but
maybe I was maybe I should still get
five million dollars anyway so this lady
clearly a little little strange we then
just got an answer to one of the
strangest questions about this whole
civil suit against Trump which is how is
it that you can take a guy to court
for something that allegedly happened 27
28 years ago long after the statute of
limitations Runs Out not only on a
criminal case but even on the civil case
how is oh because there was this law
that was passed in 2022 to create a
temporary window where you could take
someone to a civil court for something
that happened decades ago on issues like
sexual assault and rape and why did that
law get passed
can I end on something that I think is
really important in all of this and it's
the fact that New York passed this law
yeah the adult survivors act they passed
it just a few years ago were it not for
that law you never would have been able
to bring this case and I just think it
speaks to the importance for a lot of
other survivors
exactly this would never I would never
have this window this year
of having the ability uh to bring a
lawsuit for rape Robbie can explain it
better well agent actually helped to get
that law passed it passed last year
so e Gene Carroll's attorney here just
made a big mistake
she said the part that the libs were
trying to conceal which is oh yeah they
did it for us we got that law passed
they did it the whole point of that law
was to bring Trump to trial
it had nothing to do with victims of
rape or sexual assault it was just
another way to get Trump so it was
specifically for our case
that you can see the CNN hosts if not
for that wonderful law don't tell them
that they did it for you to get Trump
and then you can hear from E Gene
Carroll
this woman
whatever you think about Trump
this woman is not all there we played
the Anderson Cooper interview yesterday
from 2019 where she goes on about how oh
he didn't really rape her and actually
rape is sexy and wow Anderson you're
fascinating to talk to and she's just
she's the Christine blasey Ford of 2023.
remember Christine blasey Ford the
accuser against Brett Kavanaugh and the
media portrayed her as this dignified
woman finally coming forward after what
like 50 years or something uh she's
gonna come forward and tell her truth
finally How brave and then whenever she
would get on the microphone she sounded
like a complete Looney Tune and her
details of her story were changing
constantly and then certain facts that
she stated turned out to be lies
demonstrable proven lies and then there
was no evidence that she ever even met
Brett Kavanaugh
and you almost didn't want to blame
Christine blasey for it because every
time she spoke she sounded like she was
a couple fries away from a Happy Meal
okay not not not all there
and the same is true of this woman so
Eugene Carroll she says yes we came
forward we had to come forward okay
let's let my attorney do all the talking
now I don't what are we talking about
what's this about you're a fascinating
person to talk to
Christine blasey Ford part two speaking
of law enforcement there's some good
news coming out of Texas
the whole story today is Little Silver
Linings in big gray storm clouds
we have ten thousand people plus per day
foreign Nationals pouring across our
Southern border because we effectively
don't have a southern border anymore
and that's because Joe Biden has
intentionally opened up that border by
repealing title 42.
so
you've got all these people pouring
across the border
Biden sends some troops down to the
Border but not to repel The Invasion
he just sent the troops down to go help
the border patrol agents
process the people coming into the
country
he sent the troops down to help
facilitate the invasion so fortunately
the governors also have a say about the
State National Guards and so Governor
Greg Abbott down in Texas called to the
Texas National Guard down there
and they weren't shooting people and
they weren't clubbing people in the head
they were just standing at these border
points these illegal points of Border
entry and stopping
the foreign Nationals from coming
through and turned them around
really great stuff and it teaches you an
important lesson about politics not just
about immigration not just about who
should come in not just about should we
allow 4 million four and a half million
people come into the country every year
or maybe try to limit it to just three
and a half million or wherever the
ridiculous immigration debate is today
no it teaches you a lesson about
subsidiarity subsidiarity is a deeply
conservative principle and you can see
the principle of subsidiarity in the
American founding you can see the
principle of subsidiarity in the
Habsburg Empire okay it's it doesn't
matter the scale of your political
community
the principle of subsidiarity means that
you will push down to the most local
level decisions that can competently and
appropriately be made by that local
level so you're not going to use certain
power at the higher more centralized
level when those decisions and that
power can be exercised at a lower level
and that and that's what's going to work
Washington DC controlled by the libs is
never going to stop
illegal immigration they are only going
to encourage it it is in their political
interest either it doesn't affect them
at all and so they'll be negligent and
not do anything about it or they
actually want to undermine the Border
because it helps the Democrats
politically either way you cannot rely
on Washington DC to do it the only way
that we're going to repel any of these
waves of migration
it's going to be through the
conservative States California is
obviously not going to do it but States
like Texas
perhaps will and Greg Abbott showed that
that could happen yesterday now
I've got some bad news for you it's
bittersweet
once again
my game yes or no the greatest board
game on the internet has sold out at
dailywire.com you can't say I didn't
tell you so I warned you I said the
first time we ordered a thousand of
these games sold out almost instantly
next time we ordered many thousands more
games I said guys you got to get get it
now it's going to sell out you're gut
and then some people waited a little too
long well okay who managed to get their
hands on a copy
you got it it's coming for the rest of
you who missed out do not despair you
can still pre-order the game over at
dailywire.com shop
do not miss out I'm getting the greatest
game on the internet we've got more
exciting stuff coming about the yes or
no game all right I'm just gonna that's
a little teaser for you make sure you
get your copy though now pre-order it if
you have not ordered it already my
favorite comment yesterday is from Susan
Bailey
who says the actual verdict in the Trump
trial
we don't think Trump did anything to
this woman but we hate him
yes
that's true they passed the law to allow
this to go to trial
strictly to get trump it had nothing to
do even with the Preposterous allegation
that the woman made against him now
speaking of law enforcement
if you've ever had a conversation
with a lib about gun control
if you've ever been kind of a live
yourself
which some of us have gone through more
live faces of Our Lives okay there but
for the grace of God go we
may have heard this argument they'll say
why did that private citizen who was
protecting himself and his family in his
property against a criminal why did he
have to shoot the criminal in the chest
why couldn't he just shoot the criminal
in the leg and that way the criminal
could live maybe
and he would still be able to stop the
bad guy
why did the cops those terrible awful
cops why when they were in a shootout
with a Criminal why didn't they just
shoot him in his ankle and that way they
could stop the bad guy maybe and he
wouldn't have to die Joy Behar just
raised this question on The View
for the for the
somebody that's I can't just shoot them
in the leg why do you have to shoot them
actually having dated a homicide
detective you used to tell me when he
hears that on TV his eyes roll because
you have to shoot when you're trained
with a weapon for the mass of the body
so to shoot a leg or a wrist happens in
a James Bond film but in real life
that's actually not something that they
can do why because it's hard enough to
hit a Target so when you're shot you you
target practice on a mass which is the
main part of your body your torso so if
it's hard to hit a Target why do these
gun toters want us to constantly have
guns when we're not trained to even
shoot as well as a police officer so she
tries to save her stupid questions well
then why does any why do they want us to
have guns if we're completely untrained
I don't want you to have a gun if you
don't know how to use it
that's a straw man I certainly don't
want people who are completely ignorant
about what Firearms do and how to use
them I do not want any of you to have a
firearm for your own sake as much as for
the rest of us because if you don't know
how to use a firearm it's probably not
going to work out well for you
if you don't know how to
hold a firearm if you don't know how to
use it when there's a bad guy
approaching most likely the bad guy's
just going to take it from you and use
it on you
so we don't we want people to be
responsible and trained and be
knowledgeable about these things that
they're using this is the consequence of
ignorance
very often the people who are the
loudest activists very often the people
in office who are regulating
all of these rights and instruments in
our society they don't even understand
the mechanics of the things that they're
regulating
not only do they not understand the
philosophy of why we have a second
amendment of why we have a right to
protect ourselves of what where that
comes from what that means they don't
even understand how the pew pew thing
works they don't even know what the
trigger does they don't know what it's
like they're understanding as that woman
on The View said their understanding of
shooting a gun comes from James Bond
movies oh well why did the cops cops
have to have to stand there
and shoot the guy in the chest why
didn't they just run up jump sideways
hold the gun sideways and and shoot the
gun out of the other bad guy's hand you
know come on I saw that in the movie
Once why can't they just do that
these people have never been to a gun
range they've probably never held a gun
in their lives and this is true Beyond
gun policy this is true at all levels of
politics
the people who are doing the regulating
increasingly don't understand anything
about what they are regulating
the people who are who are passing laws
about abortion
the left Winger is passing laws about
abortion
increasingly they don't have children so
they physically don't understand what
it's like to have a baby
they often have not become pregnant
it's kind of like an inversion of the
libs argument if you're a man you
shouldn't be able to have an opinion
about abortion well okay is the same
true of a childless woman
it's the same true of a single woman who
doesn't want to
that well that's one aspect of knowledge
but then there are more important
degrees of knowledge I don't need to
have cancer to learn something about
cancer a doctor doesn't need to have
cancer to know how to treat cancer
I don't need to have committed a murder
to know how to pass a law against murder
I don't need to have been a cop to pass
a law against murder
what is required though is some basic
understanding of morality ethics
philosophy
theology ultimately
you need to know these things in order
to be a Statesman you should have a
serious education in all of these
subjects you should be able to
understand
what the law even is
not just the positive law that we all
pass and we vote up on the bill on
Capitol Hill but what the law even means
is the law merely an imposition of my
will because I want such and such to be
so in society or is the law primarily a
matter of interpretation that there is
such a thing as the natural law that
there are Eternal principles of justice
and and there there is an objective
moral order and we can perceive this and
and interpret this and then through a
process of translation translate the
Eternal moral order into the positive
law and the civil law and all the rest
of it is that of course that's what law
is well okay that means we need to know
something about ethics and morality well
what is more where do we get our Notions
of good and bad from
how can we know anything at all
the people passing our laws increasingly
don't know anything
about that
now
before we go I'm just going to tease
something before we go okay
an elderly Senator has just returned to
the Senate she's a Democrat her name is
Dianne Feinstein she's pushing 90. she's
been out of the senate for some months
now because she had shingles and she's
finally made it back and she's in a
wheelchair and she looks a bit frail and
she looked a bit frail even before she
left the Senate and there are a lot of
people calling for her to resign
a lot of Republicans calling for her to
resign a lot of conservatives and a lot
of liberals probably more liberals
actually than conservatives and the
reason for that is because the libs want
the governor in California Gavin Newsom
to be able to appoint a much younger
more left-wing Senator Dianne Feinstein
for all her sins and problems is not
even close to the most liberal member of
the U.S Senate
and so as Dianne Feinstein gets
readjusted to the Senate I want to hear
every Republican I want to hear every
single conservative come out there and
say
Diane six more years six I support
Dianne Feinstein for reelection I want
Dan Dianne Feinstein to be re-elected
three more times
I never want Dianne Feinstein to leave
the Senate
why is that some conservatives disagree
with me we'll get into a little bit more
tomorrow we're out of time now and we've
got to get to Lindsey Graham not the U.S
senator
someone far more exciting Lindsey Graham
known as the Patriot Barbie we covered
Lindsay on the show some time ago she
defied the lockdowns in Oregon in 2020
she stood up against wokeness in schools
and she is coming on this show so stay
tuned the rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it become a
member use code Knowles Canada wlas
check out for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]